GUNTHER ROLAND: The
writing skills are, I
think of, essential importance
for any of the physics majors
here.
It doesn't do you
much good if you
do the science just for itself.
You want to tell
people about it,
and you want to
be able to do that
in a professional
manner that really
gets the appropriate
appreciation
for your scientific work.
And to do that, you
need to understand
what is really the
form of communication
that scientists, physicists use.
And that is, I think, one of
the key elements in junior lab--
to really explain
how this is done,
and then through practice,
really develop that skill.
So two of the things that the
students do in 8.13 and 8.14,
in addition to performing
the experiments, is to,
A, give 15-minute presentations
on the experiments
in the style of an
APS parallel session
and write four-page papers on
each experiment in the style
of Physical Review Letter.
And I think there are
two elements to this.
And one is, of course, that this
is a large part of their grade.
So this is a skill
that we judge.
But I think it is also a
skill that the students really
develop in 8.13 and 8.14.
Most of them, before
joining the lab,
have never written a paper.
And many of them have not given
presentations in that style
before.
Some of them have.
Some of them haven't.
And so this is a skill
that they get to practice.
It's a skill that they
really need later on.
And it's also something
that many of them
are rather worried about
when starting the class.
One of our teaching--
one of our writing
instructors likes to say,
fear of public speaking
is one of the top fears
that people list when asked what
they are really worried about.
And what we tell the students,
and what they really find out
during the class, is
that public speaking
is a skill that you can really
perfect through practice.
And for me as an
instructor-- and I hope also
for the students-- seeing
the progression of them
during the semester
from really not knowing
what to do with the 15
minutes of speaking time
to having professional
presentations at the very end
is really one of the most
gratifying things in 8.13,
and then later in 8.14, to see
how much their skill really
improves over the course
of three, four months.
So there are many
ways in which we
try to help the students really
develop these communication
skills.
One is, of course,
instruction and examples.
Before they do their
first presentation,
then they give the presentation.
They meet with the
writing instructors
afterwards to go
over the presentation
and get feedback from them.
Typically, what we do is we
have 15-minute presentations
and then a 15-minute
question and answer session
that we also use to give
feedback on the presentations.
And then at the very
end of the semester,
the students take their favorite
of the three presentations
they gave during the
semester, refine it a bit,
and then give it in front
of the whole class--
again, after getting feedback
from the writing instructor.
So there's a lot of
practice, and there's
a lot of back and forth between
the students, the writing
instructors, and the lab staff.
In 8.13, obviously, at the
beginning of the semester,
there's an extremely
wide spectrum
in terms of their
communication skills.
Some people are
just naturally more
inclined to talk to
a large audience,
to present themselves,
whereas others
are mortified doing that.
And I think by the end
of 8.13, that spread
becomes much narrower.
Of course, not everybody
will have the same spirit
when giving a presentation.
But I think by the
end of 8.13, everybody
is at a level where they
have no problem giving
a 15-minute professional
presentation.
I think 8.14, the
focus really moves
from just being able to
fill the 15 minutes somehow
to a much more
detailed discussion
of the professional elements
of the presentations--
the uncertainty analysis,
really the depth
in which they examine the
data that they've taken,
and the sophistication
of the analysis methods.
I think that is more
of the focus in 8.14
after 8.13 has really
prepared them to--
just the basic tools.